How do food allergies play into my cancer diet?
We've had similar questions like this before,
like, aren't when you're testing the cheek swab,
are you testing for food allergies?
The answer is no, we're not testing for food allergies.
And no, when we put you on a cancer diet,
it has nothing to do with food allergies whatsoever.
It has to do with what's driving your cancer.
So, oh, this would be a good question.
Okay, you told me to stay off of dairy
on my cheek swab test,
but I might be in gluten free for years.
Can I start eating gluten now?
No, you can't.
So if you went off gluten at some point in the past,
it was maybe because you had a food sensitivity test
or maybe because you had recommendations
based on signs or symptoms that you had at that given time.
So just because gluten is not driving my cancer,
it doesn't mean I don't have food sensitivity to gluten.
So how do food allergies play into my cancer diet?
They're in addition to your cancer diet.
So let's say you're off dairy
because let's pretend you're off of dairy.
Let's just keep it at that.
That's a driver for your cancer.
So you're on a low, you're on a no dairy diet.
That doesn't mean that you shouldn't test for food allergies
to see if you have any other source of inflammation
that could be causing issues.
So this would be a good reason for a cancer patient
to run a Cyrex array three, array four,
or an array 10 to test for,
do you have antibodies to different foods?
And if you're eating those foods
that once you have antibodies against,
you're going to cause inflammation
and it's going to, is that going to feed your cancer?
No, but it could indirectly hinder your healing
because you're causing inflammation elsewhere.
So your body's trying to kill cancer in your breast
and every time you eat gluten,
might not be driving your cancer
but you're causing this inflammatory process
of the gut and of the brain.
Wherever any time you have inflammation
in the gut equals inflammation of the brain.
So you're causing this inflammatory cascade
and it's taking away from the immune response
that you want to be able to kill cancer cells in your breast.
So that's why I've always said it can be valuable
to run food antibody testing
even though that isn't related to what's feeding your cancer
per se, it can indirectly be hindering your ability to heal.